[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
la fin qui fait chavirer la raison au
point que l'homme on vient à dévorer
l'homme et quant à l'offre
celui qui dévorait les petits enfants il
n'a pas existé que dans les légendes
[Musique]
on n'a rien à manger et pour survivre
bon on mange des êtres humains
ça existait à plusieurs reprises et ça
existait encore tout récemment dans
notre propre société
[Musique]
bon il est à détroit de gibraltar à
l'aller
auchan qui va boucher bouger bouger
[Musique]
il démarre sous le dent que bush à
l'aide de tous bords c'est super dur
mise au saloir com
ça
[Musique]
le voyageur assailli sur la route
succombé sous les coups de ses
agresseurs
ses membres étaient déchirés grillées au
feu et dévoré
[Musique]
quelques autres présentaient à des
enfants un oeuf ou une pomme pour les
attirer à l'écart et il les immoler à
leurs fins
[Musique]
beaucoup d'historiens pense que l'église
a comme on dirige a fait connaître cette
histoire pour essayer de mettre en arrêt
à cette anthropophagie qui sévit c'est
vous dire les choses comme elles sont
qui sévit encore dans nos campagnes dans
nous arrive campagne perdue parce que
les temps étaient parfois très dure
[Musique]